(El día 9 de mayo de 2017, el Presidente
de los Estados Unidos, Donald Trump despidió
al Director del FBI, James Comey, que en aquel
momento conducía una investigación para
determinar si los asesores de Donald Trump
conspiraron junto al gobierno ruso durante
la campaña presidencial de 2016.
En los días posteriores, tal y como ha revelado
el New York Times, el FBI comenzó a investigar
si el mismísimo Presidente de los Estados
Unidos, Donald Trump es un agente al servicio
de Rusia que trabaja contra los intereses
estadounidenses y si supone un peligro para
la Seguridad Nacional.)
Vamos a ver, teóricamente la influencia de
Rusia en el mundo tendría que ser cada vez más
pequeña. ¿No os parece?
Hablamos de un país muy corrupto que con
unos 145 millones de habitantes tiene una
economía más pequeña que la del estado
de Texas; y que además vive una especie de
estancamiento crónico.
[Vamos, que apenas crece]
Sin embargo, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
esperad un momento, porque a la hora de la
verdad prácticamente no hay en todo el mundo
un solo conflicto o problema político donde
la Rusia de Vladimir Putin no esté metida
de lleno.
[Casi siempre contra los intereses de las
potencias occidentales, todo sea dicho.]
¿No me creéis?
Pues solo tenéis que pensar en la posición
de Rusia respecto a Venezuela, Cuba, Siria,
Irán, Ucrania - dónde incluso se anexionaron
Crimea -, en las elecciones en Estados Unidos,
etcétera, etcétera.
Y todo ello por no hablar de cosas como estás:
(“Ex espía ruso envenenado con un agente
nervioso en la puerta de su casa en Inglaterra")
Y es qué amigos, gracias sobre todo a su enorme
arsenal nuclear y a todos sus recursos naturales,
en política exterior Vladimir Putin hace
prácticamente lo que le da la gana.
Y como esto es algo que ya tiene muy, pero
que muy hartos a los líderes occidentales,
Es aquí cuando surge una pregunta, o mejor
dicho, la gran pregunta.
¿Cómo diantres frenar a Vladimir Putin?
[O al menos, ¿Cómo reducir su influencia
en el mundo?]
Amigos, esto es lo que hoy se preguntan en
muchas capitales, pero sobre todo en Washington.
Atentos.
(EL CASTIGO)
Quien la hace la paga… [Para evitar que
lo vuelva hacer] Esta es la respuesta de Washington.
Veréis, desde hace cuatros años - desde
la invasión de Crimea - las relaciones de
Rusia con Estados Unidos y sus aliados ha
estado dominadas por las sanciones y los castigos
económicos y políticos.
Y, ojo, porque con Trump esto no ha sido diferente.
Mas bien, todo lo contrario. La Administración
Trump ha impuesto muchas sanciones a Rusia
durante los últimos 2 años.
(“Las sanciones siguen vigentes y permanecerán
vigentes hasta que se produzca el cambio requerido
en el comportamiento ruso”, John Bolton)
Pero, claro, dicho esto nos tenemos que hacer
una pregunta, que estoy seguro muchos os habéis
hecho ya.
¿Realmente sirven para algo todas estas sanciones?
Pues… veréis, sí... y no.
Me explico. La economía rusa está sufriendo
por ellas... eso es algo que está bastante
claro. Y no es que lo diga solo el FMI.
(Alexei Kudrin, un importantísimo político
ruso, Ministro de Finanzas entre el 2000 y
el 2011; un personaje bastante cercano a Putin
y que hoy es jefe de la Cámara de Cuentas,
defiende que uno de los principales objetivos
de la política exterior de su país tiene
que ser lograr que se suavicen las sanciones
internacionales porque de otro modo los objetivos
económicos de Putin no se van a cumplir.)
[Vamos que la economía rusa lo va a pasar
mal]
Pero, claro, en todo esto hay un problema:
a Vladimir Putin que la economía rusa marche
mejor o peor pues… digamos que para él
no es lo más importante.
Sin embargo, amigos, si hay dos campos que
para él son imprescindibles. Y ojo, porque
en Washington lo saben y ya han empezado a
atacar uno de ellos. Atentos.
(EL COMPLEJO INDUSTRIAL-MILITAR RUSO)
Vale, estoy seguro de que no voy a sorprender a nadie si digo que tanto la política como la economía rusa
están muy pero que muy vinculadas al poder
militar.
Sin embargo,, ¿Hasta qué punto pensáis
que es importante la industria militar rusa?
Pues amigos, aunque mucho más pequeño que
en tiempos de la Unión Soviética;
el complejo industrial militar ruso sigue
siendo gigantesco.
Por ejemplo, da empleo a casi 3 millones de
personas…
(Es decir, ni más ni menos que 1 de cada
20 empleos en Rusia depende de la industria
militar.
Puestos de trabajo industriales que suelen
tener tasas de productividad muy altas. Y,
ojo, estamos hablando de empleos directos
sin tener, por supuesto en cuenta a los propios
soldados del ejercito ruso…
Así que… imaginaos la gigantesca influencia
que la industria militar tiene en la sociedad
y en la política de este país.)
De hecho, tan solo las 10 mayores empresas
de fabricación de armamentos de Rusia facturan
cada año casi 40 mil millones de dólares.
Y esto es mucho dinero. Hoy por hoy, tan solo
la industria militar de Estados Unidos es
más grande.
Pero, además, para Vladimir Putin la industria
militar rusa es fundamental por más motivos.
Primero por ser una enorme fuente de divisas.
Veréis, Rusia es también el segundo mayor
exportador de armas de todo el planeta. Entre
el año 2000 y el año 2017 las exportaciones
de armas rusas supusieron el 25% de todas
las exportaciones de armas en todo el mundo.
Más de 100.000 millones de dólares.
(En segundo lugar, la venta de equipos militares
es tal vez la estrategia más efectiva de
la política exterior de Rusia. Gracias a
semejante capacidad industrial, Rusia puede
ganarse el favor de países como Venezuela
que dependen del armamento ruso o puede mejorar
sus relaciones con otros a cambio de tecnología
militar, como es el caso de China o la India.)
Y por último, junto a los empleos, las divisas
y el poder político está la propia financiación
ejército ruso. Vladimir Putin paga los planes
de modernización del ejército ruso con las
ventas de armas al resto del mundo.
[Por no hablar de que la Rusia fuerte que
vende Putin no tendría ningún sentido si
no fueran capaces de producir muchas armas]
Dicho de otro modo, dañar el complejo industrial
militar ruso le supondría al país una enorme
crisis económica, perder su capacidad de modernizar el ejército y gran
parte de su influencia política en el mundo.
Pues bien, el caso es que todo es Washington lo saben.
Por eso los últimos paquetes de sanciones
se han dirigido particularmente hacia el complejo
militar causándole muchos problemas.
(Por ejemplo, tanto Estados Unidos como la
Unión Europea han restringido la venta de
muchos equipos y componentes tecnológicamente
avanzados. Ojo, no solo componentes militares
también otros que pueden ser utilizados tanto
para fines civiles como para fines militares.
Y no penséis que hablamos de poca cosa. Tan
solo la Unión Europea le vendía a Rusia
20.000 millones de dólares cada año.)
De momento las empresas rusas han tratado
de mirar hacia China… pero claro, no es
lo mismo. Y eso es algo que afecta a la efectividad
del armamento ruso y por tanto al interés
de los compradores.
Pero ahí no queda todo. Las sanciones aprobadas
implican que Estados Unidos podría llegar
a sancionar a responsables políticos y empresarios
que compren armamento ruso… lo que igual
a un venezolano le da igual, pero a personas
de otros países… puede hacerles cambiar
de opinión.
(EEUU impuso sanciones a una agencia estatal
china responsable de comprar armamento extranjero.
Las armas en cuestión fueron suministradas
por Rusia. Nikkei Asian Review)
Ahora bien, esto es lo que se ha hecho. Lo
que ahora algunos expertos plantean en Washington
es ir aún mucho más allá.
¿Cómo? Pues amigos, la clave está en los
clientes de la industria militar rusa.
Veréis, durante los últimos años…los
mejores clientes de Rusia han sido la India,
China y Vietnam. Tan solo las exportaciones
a la India y Vietnam han supuesto el 45% de
todas las exportaciones militares de Rusia
durante los últimos 4 años.
Tal vez ahora entendáis noticias como estás:
(Obama levanta el embargo de EEUU de armas
letales a Vietnam)
(EEUU reconoce a la India como su mayor socio
en defensa)
(Lockheed Martin se asocia con Tata para fabricar
cazas F-16 en la India)
Y aún más. Los países árabes, con la excepción
de Egipto, han reducido sus compras de equipos
rusos, las nuevas sanciones a Irán tampoco
le van a dar mucho margen a este país y otras
compradores importantes como Venezuela pues…
han dejado de serlo.
Además hay otra idea que se empieza a barajar en Washington;
y es que para los compradores con menos presupuesto
la industria militar Ucraniana podría ser
un duro rival para las empresas rusas, especialmente
si reciben el apoyo de los países de la OTAN.
Sí, si, no es ninguna locura.
Mirad, el 15% de toda la producción militar
soviética se hacía en Ucrania, este país
es hoy el undécimo mayor exportador de armamento
e incluso hasta el año 2013 continuó siendo
un importantísimo proveedor de la misma Rusia
En otras palabras, en Washington hay quien
defiende que facilitando la venta de armas
a los compradores de equipos rusos e impulsando
la industria militar ucraniana se le podría
asestar un duro golpe a Vladimir Putin.
(EEUU aprueba posible venta de misiles Patriot
a Turquia como apuesta para bloquear la compra
a Rusia)
Y, amigos aún queda el petróleo.
(LA SANGRE DE LA MADRE RUSIA)
La economía rusa es muy dependiente del petróleo
y el Gas Natural. Y como ya hemos visto aquí
en VisualPolitik, Rusia en un proveedor esencial
para los países de la Unión Europea. Y eso
no va a cambiar.
(Es muy triste que Alemania haga un acuerdo
masivo de gas y petróleo con Rusia, mientras
"se supone" que tú debes protegerlos frente
a Moscú, y Alemania va y les paga miles y
miles de millones de dólares al año a Rusia.
Donald J. Trump)
Pero, cuidado, a corto y medio plazo, un precio
del barril del petróleo por debajo de los
60$ y menos compras de gas por parte de los
países de la Unión Europea haría que Rusia
tuviera muchas dificultades para financiar
sus planes de modernización militar.
Ahora bien, la primera pregunta es ¿Cómo
mantener un precio del petróleo por debajo
de 60$? Pues básicamente impulsando las nuevas
fuentes de petróleo y gas.
Sí estoy hablando del fracking. Y eso es
lo que está haciendo Estados Unidos… [No
sólo ni principalmente por el conflicto con
Rusia, evidentemente, pero está ocurriendo]
La otra cuestión es, como hemos dicho, haciendo
que la Unión Europea compre menos gas a Rusia…
¿Cómo?
Pues fundamentalmente impulsando el Gas Natural
licuado que permite, por ejemplo, que países
como Australia o Estados Unidos puedan vender
sus gas por todo el mundo.
Puede ser más caro, pero una reducción de
las compras no sería algo nada pero que nada
bueno para Moscú.
(La UE está lista para facilitar más importaciones
de gas natural licuado de EEUU y este es ya
el caso mientras hablamos.Jean-Claude Juncker,
Presidente de la Comisión Europea. 08/2018)
Seguro que ahora empezáis a entender muchas
cosas. Pues bien, es que además…es el momento.
(ES EL MOMENTO)
La popularidad de Vladimir Putin en
Rusia se ha hundido en los últimos dos años
como consecuencia de la mala situación económica
y la falta de avances. Su popularidad ha perdido
más de 30 puntos.
Y no es extraño, fijaos
(En dólares el salario medio de los rusos
fue más bajo en 2018 que en 2008. Es decir,
hoy los rusos tienen menos capacidad de compra
de productos internacionales.
Desde que Putín se hizo con Crimea las cosas
no han ido bien. Y según una encuesta del
centro Levada, el 61% de los rusos consideran
que Putin es plenamente responsable de los
problemas que atraviesa el país.)
Precisamente por esto, amigos, en Washington, son muchos los que piensan que este es el momento para
atacar a Putin. Y todo apunta a que la Casa
Blanca y el Departamento de Estado han comprado
esta idea.
¿Funcionará? El tiempo nos dirá.
Amigos, si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvideis darle a like y suscribiros a VisualPolitik
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.